In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 1st, on which we commemorate St. Gregory,
the Choirmaster, Domesticals of the Great Lavra.
St. Gregory was a chanter at the Great Lavra on the Holy Mountain of Athos at the same time
as St. John Cucuceles.
Once on the eve of the Theophany, God put into his heart during the Holy Liturgy to chant
the hymn, O full of grace, thou who art the joy of all creation.
Instead of the accustomed, it is very meat to bless thee.
Whereupon the Mother of God appeared to him, thanked him, and just as she had done for St. John
Cucuceles gave him a gold coin as a pledge of her favor.
This coin has been kept ever since by the monks of the Lavra.
Having led a life acceptable to God, St. Gregory fell asleep in peace.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.